l'art contemporain à la portée des tout
petits le palais de tokyo à paris
propose des ateliers aux enfants âgés de
6 à 10 ans ils peuvent ainsi s'initier à
cet art et même exposer leur première
oeuvre
isabelle bechler demi bonne et on se
tient bien
si on regarde bien autour alors qu'est
ce qu'on voit en vaut entre 6 et 9 ans
et visitent l'exposition de l'artiste
chinois guangzhou une méga
l'installation sur la presse dont le
clou est clairement le toboggan feuilles
géantes de journal chiffonné c'est une
sculpture monumentale en aluminium et
notre petit groupe se retrouve sur la
couverture de time en tapinois m
ces téléviseurs et diffuser quoi alors
jeanne le tunnel de guangzhou il y avait
deux éléments d'information de supports
d'information la télévision et les
journaux
tanguy l'animateur décrypte les oeuvres
et stimule la curiosité des enfants
jusqu'à l'arrivée de l'artiste lui même
ils ont beaucoup de chance aujourd'hui
possible
à travers des sculptures que l'artiste a
extrapolé de la presse écrite ou de
sites d'internet il arrive à la parade
militaire
les sculptures ont tout l'exagération
que leur donne le grand angle des
photographes de presse
des six plus haut et plus
le regard de paris photo avec regard des
règles que les adultes
après la visite l'action à l'atelier
feutrine où les enfants sont inspirés
par la rencontre avec l'artiste
les basques ont par exemple
surtout dans les musées dont le musée du
louvre on ne veut pas les voir puisque
c'est que des tables en viande humaine
à chacun ses préférences
c'était la fusée qui partait et l aplomb
qui avaient le droit de
résultat a montré à maman la une d'un
journal
inspiré des oeuvres de guangzhou